So, let's spend a bit of time now looking at this new graph that Athena is using
for her box-making project. Now, I think that it's pretty incredible if we take
a second to notice just how different this new purple curve looks from this
other shape, a parabola, which we're super familiar with by now. Now, if we look
at their equations, you can notice that the defining difference between the two
equations is that this one, for the purple curve is of degree 3. And this one
for the parabola is, of course, of degree 2. So, let's explore what makes this
graph different, just a little bit deeper. So, the first things first, are both
of these graphs functions? For each equation, pick whether or not it is a
function.